bonjour je m'appelle Séverine khale j'ai
32 ans j'habite à la montagne je
recherche un emploi de serveuse sur
Saint-Denis j'ai passé le BP styliste en
2000 à du parc à Sanary en 2011 j'ai
fait le BAFA
et je m'occupe toujours des enfants
aujourd'hui actuellement je travaille
avec les enfants dans une école
élémentaire de la montagne je fais de
l'animation sportif
manuel j'ai fait un contrat de deux ans
aussi dans un restaurant les Pékinois à
Saint-Denis je suis rigoureuse
autonome
très souriante
très attentif avec les autres et je suis
très motivée pour ce métier comme je
vous l'ai dit je suis très motivée
n'hésitez pas à me contacter